مع مراسل الجزيره الياس كرام الياس على
وقع هذه الصور ل جنازه القتلى في الجنود
في صفوف الجنود الاسرائيليين ما هي ابرز
التصريحات والمواقف الاسرائيليه بعد الحدث
الاكبر كما وصف منذ بدء هذه
الحرب ايه بالفعل محمد ربما يكون ذلك
متمثلا بالبيان الثلاثي المشترك الذي
اصدره رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنيا ووزير
دفاعه يوف جلنت ووزير الوزير في مجلس
الحرب بيني جانس هذا البيان الثلاثي
المشترك الذي اراد الثلاثه ان يعبروا فيه
عن وحده الصف وعن وحده الحال ووحده المصير
ازاء ما وصفوه بالكارثي التي صعقت اسرائيل
صباح هذا اليوم بالاعلان عن مقتل 24 جنديا
وضابطا خلال الساعات ال
24 الماضيه ولعل الابرز في هذا ال
الحديث اي بالاضافه طبعا الى التعازي
ومحاوله شحذ الهمم في المجتمع الاسرائيلي
هو التاكيد على ان اسرائيل ماضيه في حربها
ومصممه على استمرار القتال واستمرار هذه
الحرب حتى تحقيق اهدافها هذا ما اكد عليه
رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو في كلمته
المقتضبه وجاء بعده ايضا وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي يوف جلنت ليؤكد على هذه
الجزئيه ايضا وكذا ذلك بطبيعه الحال بيني
جانس اذا هنالك محاوله الان من قياده هذه
الحرب من قياده مجلس الحرب في اسرائيل
المتمثله بالثلاثي نتنياهو وجانت وجانتس
على التاكيد ان هذه العمليه التي اوقعت
قتلى كثيرين في صفوف الجيش الاسرائيلي من
جنود وضباط لن تؤدي الى وقف هذه الحرب بل
على العكس هي تعطي اسرائيل ربما دافعا
لاستكمال هذه الحرب حتى تحقيق
اهدافها التي وضعتها اسرائيل هذا ما
نستطيع ان نستقي من خلال حديث رئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو الذي ما زال
يتحدث ايضا عن انجازات تحققها اسرائيل وهم
يلفتون النظر الى ما قاله الجيش
الاسرائيلي هذا الصباح على انه استكمال
لتطويق مدينه خان يونس وكنت اشرت في هذا
السياق صباح هذا اليوم بان الجيش
الاسرائيلي تعمد اصدار بيانه العسكري عن
استكمال ت ويق مدينه خانيونس ل التاكيد
للمجتمع الاسرائيلي على ان الحرب هي حرب
عادله وصادقه من وجهه نظرهم وان اسرائيل
من من الناحيه العسكريه تحقق انجازات
عسكريه على الارض رغم الاثمان الباهظه
وكان هذا البيان العسكري محاوله ربما
للتغطيه عن الخ الخساره الفادحه والكارثه
كما توصف في اسرائيل بهذا العدد الكبير من
القتلى في صفوف الجيش الاسرائيلي في عمليه
التفجير التي وقعت يوم امس